thank you
Mr President
honored guests according it's a
particular pleasure and indeed honor for
me
to welcome you home to County love
President Biden
[Applause]
we call it to we County County loud but
coming from Park I have to say president
that the Wii County packs of lunch as we
found out recently uh
but it is a company that's rich in
Tradition history a county of Legends
and a county of course of your
forefathers
I know that you visited here before
but today we are honored to welcome you
as president of the United States of
America
and we thank you president for your
ongoing support of Ireland
particularly for your profiling of our
country at every International Forum
that you attend and I noticed personally
in terms of how you've introduced many
International meetings with a quote from
Irish reports and we appreciate that
your home county like other border
counties has in part been shaped by its
proximity to the Border
and in the darkest days of the troubles
it was a place of Refuge for those
fleeing from violence
even though it itself was touched by
violence
and that's why the transformation
brought about by The Good Friday
agreement is so tangible and real here
in this location
today thousands of people seamlessly
crossed the border each day it is a
shared space a place that links rather
than divides
peace is not an abstraction here
it has become part of the daily weave of
people's lives
few would have thought this possible 25
years ago
The Good Friday agreement enables us to
make the most of people-to-people
connections across this island as well
as between Ireland and the United
Kingdom
it's three strands of relationships
reflect the depth and interwoven nature
of these engagements and together we all
have so much potential
and we want to explore that all Island
potential to its fullest
and that is why my government launched
the shared Island initiative so that we
can make the most of these opportunities
to cooperate to our Collective benefit
much has been achieved since 1998
what the remains are farther sure to
reach
we must ensure that all communities and
all traditions fully enjoyed the
benefits of peace and have the
opportunity to live on a truly
reconciled Island
and as we take forward that work Mr
President we know that we do so with the
full support of the United States
the engagement of the United States in
the peace process gave us the Good
Friday agreement
and unwavering bipartisan commitment
hereby partisan commitment that you
above all personified over the last 25
years president including through the
creation and sustainability of the
international fund for Ireland that
support continues to open up Horizons
for us
as we bidded on the Ambitions of the
Good Friday agreement to sustain a
dynamic and prosperous peace the United
States will remain a central and
fundamental partner
it is a privilege to welcome you here Mr
President
celebrate all that has been achieved and
to look forward together to The Shining
possibilities of our future
welcome home Mr President
[Applause]
Feels Like Home
I said
last time I was here
in a sense I know why my ancestors and
many of your relatives left during the
famine
and uh but you know when you're here you
wonder why anyone ever want to leave
I mean it
so it's good to be back we want to thank
another proud son of love
prime minister Martin the guy behind me
here I met him when he was
he was a teacher and the bad news was we
put him up on a lovely recorder
quarter crossing the White House
and he had covered
so uh
the fact that I'm here with my sister
Valerie my younger son Hunter Biden
Stand Up Guys I'm proud of you
[Applause]
and I wish our mom Catherine Eugenia
Finning and Biden were here today
she'd be so damn proud you know I
she allowed held such a special place in
her heart and I really did
and today we carry her home in our heart
for real we think about her all the time
and coming here feels like coming home
and it really does the way every time
I've come to welcome the people on the
streets they're just so so gracious to
us
and earlier today I had a chance to
visit another special place calling for
Castle
high in the hill the castle that was
likely one of the last glimpses that the
uh that the Finnegan family saw when
they set sail for America
and they said so with courage and hope
and they cross the sea and and through
generations defending has brought this
island
home from Ireland to Scranton
Pennsylvania where where we were raised
where I was raised I should say
and my mother lived and a matter of fact
I'm going to be heading to the other end
side of the island of the Mayo because
my uh my mother's my grandmother's
maiden name was bluitt and the blewitz
are for male
and we brought over the the mayor of
Scranton because it's a sister city to
uh to mail
and but my grandpa fennekers also say
every time I walked when I we talk about
background and Heritage Ezekiel remember
Joey best drop of blood in his Irish
I'm not kidding I'm not kidding and he'd
never been to Ireland but he raised his
family with the fierce pride in our
Irish ancestry
fry this spoke to the history that binds
us and the values that unite us
important to remember there's the values
that unite us
you know the values I heard from my
mother she used to say Joey remember
you're defined by your courage
defined by your courage and you're
Redeemed by your loyalty that was her
code you're defined by your courage
she's without courage you could never
take a chance on bus about anything
and so you know the values of my father
whose Saving Grace was a quarter of his
family with Hannah fees from Galway
that that helped you know by distinguish
I hate to tell you that I don't hate it
I'm joking but it's true
and as a matter of fact I have a call
into the former
ambassador to uh from Great Britain to
the United States who was became a
friend because the British Embassy is
alongside the fence that separates the
vice president's residence from the
British
became friends who used to always kid
him and talk about how you know lay off
the Irish man they're not joking with
him and one day he said Biden's English
I said no it's dutch I was joking
and make a long story short his last
tour he came home to England and I later
learned went to the Admiral team to
determine because he knew the name Biden
was English
and he found that my great great
grandfather I think was I am trying to
find the book in 18
28 or 38 I can't recall
was a captain in the in East Indian tea
company and he got the reprint a book
The Admiral to reprint a book he wrote
the rules of mutiny
seriously for the British neighbor
and there's a picture of him sitting in
his cabin looking very captainish with a
big British Bulldog next to him and he
gave me the book said I don't want to
hear anymore
but all Kitty aside you know uh
the fact is that you know my dad taught
us a lot
and he used to our dinner table was a
place where you accidentally sat down to
eat and but it was a place we had
discussions
my dad our dad worked like hell and he'd
come home from work and then go back
we'd have dinner at six o'clock and it
was a place as I said we had
conversation and incidentally ate and
then we go back to work until nine
o'clock
and uh but my dad had this in North he
was a really a fine man and he talked
about his favorite word was that dignity
he said everyone Everyone's entitled to
be treated with dignity Joey and respect
no matter what my father would no more
walk by the shoeshine guy in the Hotel
DuPont then he would walk by the Chamber
of the board who walked by
it so that was my our dad and he meant
it everyone
these are the same values I've tried to
pass down to my children my son Hunter
I'm going to see son bull my daughter
Ashley that that everyone everyone is
entitled to be treated with dignity
everybody
I know the same value as I uh that we
that including my granddaughters
I have a great thing about
granddaughters is they're crazy about
their grandfather
I've worked on it for the very you think
I'm joking I worked on the very
beginning and my number two
granddaughter and when I walked in my uh
she was being born and Hunt was there
and I had just had been born we walked
into the recovery room and I said what
are we going to name her and he said
Finnegan
and I said no what are we going to name
her
and because I thought Catherine Eugenia
fitting in mind they're gonna neighbor
he said no Finnegan I said what are we
going to call her I said Finnegan dad
Finnegan
finnig is a works for an international
company now she's a great kid and but
look
the fact is I've often said the Irish
are the only people in the world
in my view who actually are nostalgic
about the future
think about it
the nostalgic about the future I think
we all are no matter where we live if we
have our respond to this and it's
because more than anything
more than anything in my experience hope
is what beats in the heart of all people
particularly in the heart of the Irish
hope
every action is about hope we can make
things better
and hope to build both our Nations and
have been passed down generation to
Generation by our families
and let's hope that continues this day
nearly 45 years ago as some of you may
remember none of you women are old
enough to know but some of you men may
be 45 years ago Pope John Paul spoke
down the road
quoting St Patrick
the pope said and I quote
I have kept the faith and it's been the
ambition of the Irish down through the
centuries to have kept the faith
I think that's who we are we keep the
faith
I'm not talking about religion per se
I'm talking about Keeping the Faith the
faith in who we are what we believe what
our values are
so my message you today is quite simple
we have to continue to keep the faith
every time I walk out there's not a joke
walk out of my grandpa Finnegan's house
up in Scranton Pennsylvania he tells
Joey keep the faith and then my uncle
and my grandmother would yell no joy
spread it spread it but all together we
have to keep working toward the future
that's
of Greater dignity and as we Face
darkness and there is Darkness we have
to face
but we must keep marching forward
because the world is a greater
it's just the world has such
possibilities I was a Xi Jinping I spent
more time with them than the world
leader has over the last 10 years
and over they keep a meticulous count as
the former teach
ER and over now
87 hours worth
and I was in the Tibetan Plateau with
them I traveled 17 000 miles in China
over 10 years
and he asked me he said can you define
America for me I could say the same of
Ireland
I suggest I can I said in one word
possibilities
we believe anything is possible
anything's possible anything's possible
if we set our mind to it
that's who we are
that's what we believe in my view so let
me close with this
around the time only reported the
brothers Bound for the ship the brothers
Bound for America
another Shoemaker named Joseph Kearney
from moneygall was leaving because my
great great grandfather was a was a
Shoemaker
and uh he sailed on the Carolyn Reed and
arriving in America just five weeks
before my great-great-grandfather
and there are both shoemakers
and it's doubtful they knew each other
and they came they came they came out of
the same port
and but one thing we do know
they left everything behind and what
they had faith
that faith is an uncertain future
in all their dreams I'm not sure they
could have imagined that 175 years later
both their great great grandsons to be
president of the United States of
America Barack Obama and Joe Biden
but that's what you breed here
just faith and the possibilities that
are out there you know we come from
Valerie and I come from not poor means
but modest means we lived in a split
level home and the development of
similar homes of 75 homes so it was a
nice neighborhood
and we had three bedrooms four kids and
a grandpa living
one and uh but it was uh it was home I
now look back and wonder how Mom and Dad
did that but but but the point is that
you know there's just there's just we we
were taught anything's possible
Anything is Possible and uh so uh the
fact is that
I think possibilities are what we have
to be focused on and that's the power of
Faith that's the promise of hope and so
uh as my mother would say
that's the Irish of it that's the Irish
show whenever we say something was
unusual she said Joey that's the Irish
of it and
I'm so proud to be here so proud to be
in love so proud to be with I don't want
to ruin the reputation but
yeah
we take great faith in the closing
comment I make you see this tie I have
with a shamrock on it this was given to
me by one of these guys right here it
was a hell of a rugby player and they
beat that little black and tans oh my
God but but it was when you were a
soldier field wasn't it Chicago
and uh after all over uh he gave my
brother allegedly for me but if it
wasn't I still took it I still got the
tie where it was great pride and so
thank you all for the coming welcome the
bad news for all you is we'll be back
there's no way to keep us out but thank
you thank you thank you
[Applause]